they make it their business to mind your
business
homes like this to be labeled flight
after Ridgefield Connecticut passed a
new ordinance that lets officials need
out $250 day fines for homes they deem
to be I stores and in Los Angeles
everyone's under investigation
two dozen police agencies are using
cameras mounted on police cruisers and
fixed locations to monitor the
whereabouts of drivers that sustain
technology of military uses to track
insurgents in Afghanistan and Iraq but
don't worry if you're not doing anything
wrong you have nothing to fear but hey
who's your nanny this month or messing
with Texas because Frisco Texas is
messing with a man for warning drivers
about speed traps cops didn't just
ticket Ron Martin for violating an
ordinance against holding a sign in a
center median they arrested him oh and
one more thing they arrested him for
something that isn't illegal released or
wasn't until Frisco police chief John
Bruce issued a formal request for an
ordinance that the City Council
dutifully passed in March several months
after Martin's arrest a judge dropped a
misdemeanor charge against Martin who's
made a habit of warning drivers about
cops
the chief insists Martin's arrest was
still valid that decided against
refiling the charge under the new
ordinance pedestrians may pause in the
center median to wait for traffic to
clear while crossing the street but
standing on the median is illegal
because it's dangerous so why is it okay
to pause but illegal to stand well you
can bet the chief has a darn good reason
that has nothing to do with depriving
the city of speed ticket revenue fallen
Ann is a month on Twitter submit your
nanny nominees and check back next month
for more examples of busybodies minding
your business